is equal to one centimeter and you see
we have to find the length of VD in this
question so let's assume b d to be equal
to X centimeter the AC will also be
equal to X Plus 1 centimeter this is 72
degrees over here so therefore angle a
will also be equal to 72 degrees because
angles opposite to equal sides of a
triangle are equal now if you use angle
some property in this triangle ADB now
you see over here we can say DC is equal
to da now the question is we have to
find the value of x that is b d over
here if I write it AC by a b that will
come out to be equal to CD by DB guys
basically in order to find the value of
x we have to solve this quadratic
equation which we can do using the
quadratic formula because you will not
be able to factorize this quadratic
equation